dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir reinforcement
learning is an awesome algorithm that is
able to play computer games navigate
helicopters hit a baseball or even
defeat NGO champions when combined
together with a neural network and Monte
Carlo tree search it is a quite general
algorithm that is able to take on a
variety of difficult problems that
involve observing an environment and
coming up with a series of actions to
maximize a score in a previous episode
we had a look at deepmind's algorithm
where a set of movement actions had to
be chosen to navigate in a difficult 3d
environment efficiently the score to be
maximized was the distance measured from
the starting point the further our
character went the higher score it was
given and it has successfully learned
the concept of locomotion really cool a
prerequisite for a reinforcement learner
to work properly is that it has to be
given informative reward signals for
instance if we go to a written exam as
an output we would like to get a
detailed breakdown of the number of
points we got for each problem this way
we know where we did well and which
kinds of problems need some more work
however imagine having a really careless
teacher who never tells us the points
but would only tell us whether we have
failed or passed no explanation no
points for individual tasks no telling
whether we failed by a lot or just a
tiny bit nothing first attempt we failed
next time we failed again and again and
again and again now this would be a
dreadful learning experience because we
would have absolutely no idea what we
improve clearly this teacher would have
to be fired
however when formulating a reinforcement
learning problem instead of using more
informative scores it is much easier to
just tell whether the algorithm was
successful or not it is very convenient
for us to be this careless teacher
otherwise what score would make sense
for a helicopter control problem when we
almost crash into a tree this part is
called reward engineering and the main
issue is that we have to adapt the
problem to the algorithm where the best
would be if the algorithm would adapt to
the problem this has been along
problem in reinforcement learning
research and the potential solution
would open up the possibility of solving
even harder and more interesting
problems with learning algorithms and
this is exactly what researchers at open
AI try to solve by introducing hindsight
experience replay a gr or her in short
very apt this algorithm takes on
problems where the scores are binary
which means that it either passed or
failed the prescribed task a classic
careless teacher scenario and these
rewards are not only binary but very
sparse as well which further exacerbates
the difficulty of the problem in the
video you can see a comparison with a
previous algorithm with and without the
her extension the higher the number of
epochs you see above the longer the
algorithm was able to Train the
incredible thing here is that it is able
to achieve a goal even if it had never
been able to reach it during training
the key idea is that we can learn just
as much from undesirable outcomes as
from desirable ones
let me quote the authors imagine that
you're learning how to play hockey and
are trying to shoot a puck into a net
you hit the puck but it misses the net
on the right side the conclusion drawn
by a standard reinforcement learning
algorithm in such a situation would be
that the performed sequence of actions
does not lead to a successful shot and
little if anything would be learned it
is however possible to draw another
conclusion namely that this sequence of
actions would be successful if the net
had been placed further to the right
they have achieved this by storing and
replaying previous experiences with
different potential goals as always the
details are available in the paper make
sure to have a look now it is always
good to test things out whether the
whole system works well in software
however its usefulness has been
demonstrated by deploying it on a real
robot arm you can see the goal written
on the screen alongside with the results
a really cool piece of work that can
potentially open up new ways of thinking
about reinforcement learning after all
it's great to have learning algorithms
that are so good they can solve problems
that we formulate in such a lazy way
that we
have to be fired and here's a quick
question do you think eight of these
episodes a month is worth a dollar if
you have enjoyed this episode and your
answer is yes please consider supporting
us on patreon details are available in
the video description thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time
[Music]